bon bien
un bonjour à tous merci d'être là je
suis ravi qu'ils aient autant de monde
dans cet amphi à
donc comme
il y en a de préciser je m'appelle
olivier passalacqua et aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler d'informatique et plus
précisément comment en fait
l'informatique a pu donner un sens à ma
carrière et j'ai illustré ça avec le
domaine industriel dans lequel je
travaille actuellement pour commencer je
vais vous demander de faire une petite
expérience un peu immersive ceux qui le
souhaitent peuvent fermer les yeux je
vais vous demander de vous imaginer
étudiants donc là normalement ça devrait
aller et vous projetez début juillet
vous venez de terminer votre année
universitaire et vous apprêtez à
commencer un job d'été ce job d'été est
assez particulier puisque vous allez
travailler dans une usine qui fabrique
de la laine de roche et vous vous
apprêtez à travailler deux mois dans un
atelier de conditionnement dans lequel
vous allez devoir mettre des dalles de
faux plafond dans un carton toute la
journée
alors à vous êtes motivé vous commencez
votre journée
et puis vous vous apercevez assez
rapidement que la laine de roche
c'est comme on vous l'a sans doute déjà
dit c'est assez irritant c'est pas très
agréable et même s'il fait chaud et bien
on vous décourage fortement de travail
et en t-shirt puisque après les
particules vont rentrer dans les pores
de la peau et même après une bonne
douche ça gratte quand même un vrai
journée de travail
dès que vous mettez des dédales de faux
plafond dans les cartons vous vous
apercevez qu'il ya des petites
particules de poussière qui vous arrive
dans le visage
un régal tout ça pour vous dire que j'ai
une expérience que j'ai vécue et qui m'a
suffisamment marqué pour que je me rende
compte à quel point travail dans les
usines c'est pas toujours bien glamour
et puis
ça m'a donné en fait de motivation la
première travailler un peu plus
l'université pour par piqué encore une
fois une année et plus récemment je me
suis demandé si je pouvais pas appliqué
mon savoir faire pour aider le quotidien
des ouvriers pour qui c'est pas toujours
rose tous les jours on va refermer un
peu cette parenthèse assez désagréable
sur cette job d'été dans la laine de
roche
j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure et
maintenant je vous proposais un petit
sondage parmi vous quels sont ceux qui
ont eu dans les six derniers mois
l'occasion soit deux touchés soit de
goûter un des trucs qui est à l'écran
vous pouvez lever la main sans surprise
vous êtes une grande majorité voire
quasiment l'unanimité à avoir soit
goûter du saucisson du fromage touché
des gommes ou mais un lave vaisselle en
août
tout ça pour vous dire que la quasi
totalité des personnes que je rencontre
et bien participe à acheter des produits
industriels que ce soit dans
l'agroalimentaire ou alors sinon dans
l'équipement en fin de les fournitures
de bureau et vous vous allez avoir là
l'opportunité de pouvoir être acteur
également dans ceux qui travaillent dans
les industries que vous allez pouvoir
faciliter leur vie
voilà vous expliquer comment je prends
un premier exemple avec les entreprise
de salaisons donc les saucissons jambons
et ce genre de choses
actuellement en rhône alpes il ya plein
de vignes de ce style imaginez un
opérateur qui est entré chez une marque
très connue qui fait des saisissant et
il est entré il ya à peu près 20 ans et
mettons dans cette société il a vu
toutes les révolutions toutes les
évolutions dans son atelier est
aujourd'hui eh bien il se retrouve à
mettre des saucissons à intervalles
règle
lle sur un tapis roulant pour que il
machine qui les emballe alors au début
ça allait d'une part il était plus jeune
il ya 20 ans et puis les cadences de
production était un peu moins élevé mais
vous comme moi on aime bien avoir des
saucissons pas trop cher donc il fallait
faire des économies et pour faire des
économies plus 1 c'était augmenter la
cadence et jusqu'à ces dernières années
louis c'était un opérateur que j'ai
rencontré devait mettre 50
ce 6 courbes comme ça sur le convoyeur
par minute
inutile de vous dire qu'à la fin de la
journée il était complètement rasées et
puis je vous parle pas de le côté peu
valorisant de de ce travail la société
qui l'emploie nous a demandé d
automatiser son poste de travail
ainsi c'est l'autre bouton on a
participé en fait à l'automatisation à
l'installation d'un robot qui est chargé
de mettre les produits sains sur le
convoyeur et louis et bien louis-paul
jeu tu le prennes angeli bref
l'opérateur lui sa mission a évolué et
il doit conduire en fait la cellule
robotisée d'accord donc ce projet
voilà l'exemple donc on doit localiser
un les saucisses qui sont sur un tapis
roulant on a une caméra là juste
derrière avec une lumière adapté qui va
pouvoir nous aider à faire ressortir
chaque saut 6 par rapport au tapis
roulant et ensuite nous on doit
localiser un chaque produit pendant son
convoyage et vérifier que l'outil qui au
bout du robot bien sera en mesure de
prendre la saucisse et la poser à
intervalles réguliers ici
donc ça on l'a réalisé maintenant en
plus la machine elle réalise une cadence
plus élevé que l'opérateur précédemment
donc
on a participé d'une part à faire que le
travail des opérateurs soient moins
fatiguant et puis c'est plus valorisant
que ces missions ont évolué vers de la
conduite de machines autonomes presque
tout un autre exemple il ya quelques
années une entreprise qui fait des du
fromage est venu nous voir parce qu'il y
avait un dilemme c'est à dire que en
dessous d'un certain nombre de fromages
qui sortent de lusine par jour par heure
il n'était plus assez rentable et ils
nous ont dit bon bah voilà
soit on garde une entreprise qui vous
trop cher en france soit on l'a
délocalise dans l'europe de l'est
donc on s'est dit bon on va peut-être
proposer une solution
le poste en question il était pareil
assez simple ici ce sont des fromages
qui sortent de la finale ils sont sur
des grandes grilles et ensuite il y
avait deux opératrices qui était chargé
de de décoller
chaque fromage pour les maîtres pareil à
intervalles réguliers devant une machine
qui est chargé de mettre de l'emballage
pareil toute la journée
elle devait 2 pour assurer une certaine
cadence un certain nombre de produits
qui sortent par heure de là donc on a
réalisé ce projet on à automatiser le
deck l'eia
c'est à dire enlever les fromages des
grilles et la dépose des fromages sur
sur un tapis roulant à intervalles
réguliers
on a participé également aux
modifications des missions de la
conductrice de ligne qui maintenant
n'est plus opératrice elle doit gérer
des robots donc on a préservé une
industrie localement et en plus on a
fait évoluer les missions d'une
opératrice voilà l'illustration
ici il faut imaginer que on est donc
dans une usine de l'agroalimentaire de
des produits laitiers et l'espace était
très réduit parce que forcément
l'automatisation d'un poste
ce fait à périmètre constant j'irai
d'accord à surface constante quasiment
équivalente donc dans un espace très
restreint
on nous a demandé d'automatiser tout ça
et donc on a proposé d'installer un
énorme robot qui est assemblé pas très
loin ce robot il est chargé de prendre
des grilles deux par deux quand les
fromages sorte de l'affinage ensuite ici
on a un dispositif qui est chargé de
décoller à l'aide de doigts en silicone
chaque fromage qui est sur la grille qui
étaient soudés en fait lors de la finale
la petite fleur qu'il ya sur le fromage
est là elle reste collée contre le la
grille ensuite là où il y à de la
lumière c'est là où on va localiser
chaque fromage et l'ordinateur lui va
envoyer un ton va envoyer les
coordonnées de chaque fromage aux deux
robots qui vont être chargés de se
synchroniser pour répartir en fait quels
sont les produits que chacun des deux va
prendre
et puis pour les déposer à intervalles
réguliers et là on le voit pas l'idée
hors champ mais il ya un troisième un
quatrième robot qui est chargé de
prendre les grilles lorsqu'il ya plus de
fromage pour pouvoir les mettre
vers la sortie de la cellule pour les
les assemblées en vue de leur lavage mon
sens la réaliser il a réalisé deux fois
dans la même usine
donc on a automatisé deux fois quatre
postes
un dernier exemple ici nous sommes dans
une usine qui fabrique un des pastilles
de lave vaisselle alors vous le voyez
pas à l'écran mais ici là chaque carton
fait vingt kilos chaque carton est
rempli d emballage qui vont servir à
contenir les pastilles de la vaisselle
donc il y avait un opérateur pareil qui
était chargé de prendre chaque carton de
l'ouvrir de la mettre sur un convoyeur
de enlevé le carton et de ranger carton
toute la journée des cartons de 20 kg
l'industriel pareil nous a proposé
d'automatiser ce poste
avec les aides avec l'aide de des
collègues de la conception mécanique on
a réalisé un préhenseur polyvalent qui
permet d'une part de localiser
précisément les cartons qu'on doit
manipuler
parce que forcément les palettes à sont
pas parfaites assuré forcément le
déplacement de ses cartons sur le
convoyeur qu'on a vu sur la partie
gauche de l'écran là l'outil il est
suffisamment polyvalent pour pouvoir
prendre les intercalaires il est même
dans une benne pour le recyclage et
ensuite le robot va prendre le carton à
vis des îles le renverse
il le laisse pour servir de blocs en
fait pour éviter que les cartonnettes
tombe ici là sur la partie gauche de
l'écran on l'appelle où on l'a vu assez
rapidement ce sont tous les petits
emballages qui vont servir à être ouvert
et à recevoir les passifs de la
vaisselle et là le robot il est équipé
d'une petite lame qui sert à découper le
scotch très précisément sur le carton
donc les collègues de la robotique voilà
ils ont des trajectoires au quart de
millimètre j'irais là est un dispositif
qui permet d'ouvrir le carton est comme
ça le robot lui
ben voilà il plie le carton et ensuite
il va le mettre au recyclage
maintenant la personne qui faisait toute
la journée
eh bien elle peut se consacrer 1 à
surveiller que le robot fonctionne bien
et à peu faire d'autres tâches
pour résumer là où je veux en venir
c'est que par exemple dans mes deux
précédentes expériences j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire aussi de
l'informatique du logiciel ce que je
vais vous dire c'est va là pour plein
d'autres domaines
avant je faisais de la vidéosurveillance
et le jour je me suis rendu compte que
les logiciels était surtout utilisé pour
fliquer une caissière que résoudre des
délits je me suis dit que j'étais pas
franchement intéressant et puis pareil
longtemps le cloud ont échangé des mails
entre google et microsoft avec plusieurs
milliers d'utilisateurs
et quand on avait migré plus de 100
millions de mails bon le dernier
pourcentage de mecs n'avaient pas
fonctionné c'était toujours celui là qui
posait problème c'est pas très palpitant
non plus et aujourd'hui est bien avec
les collègues qui sont des mécaniques
ceux qui font des automatismes et de la
robotique
je trouve que c'est un peu plus sympa
dd le quotidien en fait des différents
opérateurs qui ont des tâches assez
ingrate ou peu valorisantes où sur 2 cms
ça participe à la préservation
d'industrie en france et en plus ça crée
des emplois particulièrement qualifié
automaticien roboticiens par ailleurs il
n'y a absolument pas besoin d'attributs
sexuée spécial spéciaux pour manipuler
un robot il suffit juste d'un clavier et
d'une souris d'accord actuellement pour
illustrer ce que l'on cherche dans ce
domaine comme comme profil j'ai pris un
exemple d'une machine qu'on a sur notre
catalogue
allez assez imposante ici vous avez deux
ans qu'est ce qu'ils sont chargés de
prendre des sachets de fruits secs pour
les mettre dans des cartons ensuite les
cartons sorte de ces deux machines sur
les tapis roulants avec les petits
rouleaux et il ya un gros robot qui au
milieu qui est chargé groupe et les
cartons deux par deux et ensuite les
poser sur des palettes pour réaliser ce
type de projet nous avons besoin
d'automaticien avec qu'ils sont
à l'aise avec plusieurs technologies on
a une véritable évolution de ce métier
vers la programmation et des standards
pour échanger avec les différents corps
de métiers c'est des choses que je vous
conseille de demander si vous faites de
l'automatisme à vos enseignants pareil
pour la robotique la robotique là je
voudrais citer deux exemples ce sont les
deux marques que l'on que l'on intègre
le plus souvent donc là c'est un gros
c'est un robot dans chaque machine
ici la plus le robot de palettisation et
enfin au niveau de l'informatique
on a besoin de personnes crise qui
savent qu'ils sont en mesure de
développer des logiciels qui vont faire
l'interface entre l'opérateur et la
machine est également qu'ils vont être
expert en traitement d'image par exemple
pour localiser comme tout à l'heure les
saucisses pleurs de leur convoyage par
il ya plein de technologies qui existent
là je vous ai montré vers quoi je suis
arrivé d'accord à présent un des
derniers projets et que j'ai réalisé
c'est pour un client qui fabrique des
gommes à argonay c'est juste à côté
le robot là il est chargé de coupler
deux types de gommes pour pouvoir les
mettre dans le même blister donc la
partie informatique qui me concerne doit
être en charge de localiser chacune des
gommes savoir si elle est dans le bon
sens pour que le logo il soit dans le
fond du blister pour que ce soit
correctement mis dans les rayons et en
plus si on pouvait orienter les gommes
de façon à ce qu'elle soit tout est qu
un biseau dans le même sens ce serait
mieux et je me suis dit que ben voilà
après deux mois avoir bien réfléchi à ce
projet à avoir acquis une certaine
expertise et bien ça pourrait être
réutilisé dans d'autres domaines
ici la bon on fabrique des des morceaux
de plastique et la bomba on essaie de
les valoriser un autre exemple en ce
moment on est en train de mettre en
place une 6 un système de déplacement
autonome de charges lourdes dans les
usines typiquement ce petit robot
il va être responsable de tirer des
poubelles ou des chariots dans les
allées dans les allées des usines donc
il doit être autonome et bien je me dis
que l'expertisé et les compétences qu'on
va acquérir dans ce domaine de robots
autonomes dans un milieu qu'il connaît
pas forcément bien ça pourrait être
réutilisé dans d'autres domaines plus
sympa je peux faire des robots autonomes
dans l'espace pourra pas tout ça pour
vous dire que là vous en est qu'au début
en fait de votre parcours vous êtes en
train d'acquérir plein de compétences
vous savez à peu près vers vous allez à
lire dans les domaines qui sont les
vôtres
mais gardez bien en tête que et bien
c'est vous qui êtes responsable de a
l'objectif final est en aucun cas il
faut vous fermer des portes et des
opportunités
la dernière citation que je voudrais
donner que j'ai retenu que j'essaie de
m'appliquer c'est si vous n'avez pas
envie d'être déçus par le futur
le meilleur moyen ça reste d'y prendre
part je remercie
[Applaudissements]